[Music]
there is a new National monument in
southern Nevada President Biden
officially designated avaame or Spirit
Mountain earlier today this is supposed
to protect lands considered Sacred by
several Native American peoples this
move also stopping a wind power energy
project that's being developed in the
area
Republican Governor Joe Lombardo saying
this designation will quote cost of
add-ins for generations to come he is
criticizing the move saying the White
House is not releasing enough
information and will disrupt Mining and
land developments he considers crucial
for the future of Nevada